[Music]
good evening everybody welcome back to
another developer update last year for
the first time our first event ever we
ran the Summer Games and we learned so
much from running that event you guys
gave us tons of feedback as you saw
throughout the year we iterated and
changed our future events based on that
initial run with Summer Games now I've
been paying attention to a lot of social
media and I've been hearing the buzz
everybody asking about when is Summer
Games coming back well now is the time
Summer Games is coming back very soon
and we wanted to set you up with some
pertinent information so you knew what
was going to be the same and what was
going to be different about Summer Games
this year so first of all a question on
a lot of people's minds is are the skins
that were available in Summer Games 2016
going to be available again this year
and the answer is absolutely yes we know
you want a chance to get that American
McCree skin or the nihon Gangi you will
absolutely be able to get those skins
again now the other thing if you
remember and not all of you are around
back for summer games 2016 but back then
those skins were not available for
unlock via the credit system and that
was something that we changed based on
your feedback well this is going to be
the first year that Summer Games is
going to run where you'll be able to
unlock the old skins for credits as long
as as well as the new skins that are
coming too so that is also awesome now
as I mentioned there's new skins and new
content coming as well and I don't want
to spoil it all but I'll give some hints
road hog
I'm sorry road hog is not getting
anything so that was just me being silly
junk rat is going to get an awesome
legendary skin and I think I think you
guys are gonna love it
it's very sports themed and our favorite
Australian is going to get a great skin
merci and that's why I'm wearing this
shirt today
merci is getting one of my favourite
skins of all time and I'm so excited for
you guys to check it out and we have
some other cool things happening as well
I think Widowmaker and McCree found
are gonna be really blown away with what
we're gonna go into deliver and there's
some silly stuff too and I'll just I'll
just leave that for you guys and you'll
know what I'm talking about in a little
bit but the new skins will be available
for credit unlocks just like every event
and as I mentioned those old skins are
available too but we're going to do
something different for the old skins
we're going to discount the prices to
normal loot box prices for the credit
cost of those skins so for example if
you want tracer in her runner skin that
she had in Summer Games 2016 which was a
legendary it will only cost you 1000
credits versus the 3,000 credits that an
event legendary normally costs we think
that bringing the old items back is
absolutely key for our players who
weren't able to get them the first time
around and we also want to discount them
somewhat so more of you can get more of
those items you want and love while
still reserving some specialness for the
brand new stuff so not everybody's
running around in all the coolest most
brand-new stuff we also want to remind
you that we've made significant loop box
changes which you guys have already seen
a little bit of in our normal loop box
in regards to duplicates so we
drastically reduced the rate at which
you're going to get duplicates and we've
never before felt this in one of our
event loop boxes before so summer games
will be the first time that you're
experiencing the much reduced duplicate
rate in the loop boxes so we think
that'll be awesome
now a lot of you are thinking enough
with the rambling about skins and loop
boxes all we really care about when it
comes to summer games as lucio ball is
it coming back and the answer is yes
lucio ball of course is coming back not
only that but we have our beautiful Rio
stadium that we built for 2016 and we're
proud to introduce Sydney Australia as a
new stadium for lucio ball to take place
in now we've also made some tweaks to
lucille ball based on feedback from the
first time around there's a couple
things that have changed one you can no
longer stand in the
enemy goal and Boop the enemy goalie out
of the way we've removed the ability to
Boop your enemies because a lot of
people were finding that frustrating and
we also changed Lucio's ultimate in
lucio ball it used to pull the ball
towards you very dramatically and there
were sort of some cheesy strategies
about pooping the goalie stand and the
goal pull the ball and we made that go
away so now when you use Lucio's
ultimate you move much faster you can
use his alternate ability to Boop the
ball much more quickly and he jumps a
lot higher so it's sort of like super
lucio when he uses that ultimate we
think you guys will really enjoy it we
think the change is really healthy to
lucio ball and that'll be great now the
thing that is probably most exciting
about lucio ball coming back is we've
really upped the stakes this time not
only can you just play lucio ball like
you enjoyed it last year in summer games
but we've also added a new card to the
arcade that's called copa lucille ball
and what this means is competitive
Lucille Ball that's right for three
weeks during the summer games we're
going to be running a competitive
Lucille Ball system not only that if you
place if you play your ten games
competitively in Lucille Ball you will
get a special spray if you make it into
the top 500 of Lucille Ball players in
your region you will get an additional
special spray so we can't wait to see
how you guys do to see what your skill
ratings are to see you know how great of
a Lucille Ball player are you versus a
normal overwatch player we think this
three-week season concept could be a lot
of fun outside of Lucille Ball even so
we want to see how you guys respond to
it we want to see how you guys play with
it and what you think about that so
that's an overview of summer games we're
going to be releasing even more
information leading up to the event we
think you guys will have a ton of fun as
always we're listening to you for
feedback and if we need to make changes
we will we hope you guys in joyed
Lucille Ball summer games that
all the new loot box content and have a
blast playing thanks
[Music]